what up vlog it's a you know just
abnormal 234 in the morning here in
Atlanta outside the studio
you know just an horrible day you got
your perspective
[Music]
excuse factory is open I mean I'm
literally showing people how to make
three four five six seven eight nine
hundred bucks extra a month minimum and
they're like what stop my worth my time
and these are the same people if I
complain for nine for four hours or
Madden or just I'm moping around on the
front porch like it's laughable
so just look them up he's in Buffalo
some literally on Craigslist Buffalo
right now I'm putting in the work and
I'm gonna show
here's free firewood dude look at this
I'm gonna
is it right dude you live in Buffalo I
looked it up
I just went to Buffalo Craig's List free
the third thing I saw was this
you go pick that up and realistic hot
and realist it on Facebook marketplace
and you'll make a hundred bucks
do that 10 times and you made AG
better than Netflix
[Music]
teach them how to fish teach them how to
[ __ ] fish I can teach people how to
fish two ways the best way to teach
people how to fish is watch what I'm
[ __ ] doing watch it all of it why am
i podcasting what am I putting my
Instagram stories why I'm on LinkedIn
why do I have an email set up for me why
am i doing these things watch watch
watch watch watch why do I read a lot of
copy why am I in my comments or I can
teach people how to fish literally the
180 strategy the 86 page deck the
explosion on Twitter on how to use
Craigslist to make and Facebook
marketplace to make $1,000 if you hustle
for every [ __ ] person that's watching
period which is a lot of money for 75%
of people that are watching I'll teach
you how to fish two ways you just have
to [ __ ] fish
[Music]
what a first line Chicago to Alabama
I think there right now you're gonna get
this text very shortly saw me there this
is the barter sight or the sneakers very
excited about these three levels the
party's gonna be insanity yeah yeah new
Mike says sure you know yeah that's my
brother if you under water broke thank
you again there we go
what's super interesting about this as
I've gone to campuses most places have
like you know the guys have gone to
League you've got so many that you've
had to put the like rotate huh this is
nice keeping up with the Joneses is yeah
I'm aware of what that is that's cool
all only here okay downstairs of this
dining facility is every other sport
okay these guys have no clue how good
they got it they've got a good boy
practice fields got three natural grass
fields the indoors with the windows the
indoor practice facility the brick
building amazing man it's crazy what a
program huh the absolutely demands that
his players are surrounded by the very
best people and resources possible he's
doing a pretty damn good job of it it
sure is a lot of winning helps get a lot
of leverage to be able to do any need to
do know that a Bama
this is pretty cool this this one did
not work out for us unfortunately
[Music]
alaya this sounds whatever you nice is
pretty much the most like this little
thing right here could be the deal
sealer for some guys this might have
made me commit no excuses exactly right
hey JT I'm Gary nice to meet you man how
you doing good real good thank you so
much awesome I'm really glad to be here
dude I'm so pumped to be here he'll know
what a [ __ ] facility Jesus Christ no
wonder you guys win every [ __ ] game
man there's so much of what even I saw
in the hallway that I'm like yep no
excuses is [ __ ] everything you
eliminate that everything changes you
actually you take on you you embrace
accountability and it's [ __ ] game
over in life I believe in that [ __ ] so
much you know Gary real pleasure how are
things
Marcus he rocks so now I'm in Vayner
sports I start this thing you know like
crazy story I bought it because I wanted
to learn because I want to buy the Jets
and not even really thinking about it
like was really gonna be like this thing
I watch just to learn the game just to
be player friendly one day that my
brother who has Crohn's disease decides
to bounce out of vaynermedia and then
like a month into him thinking about his
futures like I want to run this I'm like
let's go I love this you have the
jitters I'm very excited right now he
just believed a bet I'm in the best mood
it's amazing you know some people see
the cross or a Jewish star that's my
religion I see this and I'm like excited
that's what's up an or and that was the
you know I tore both my meniscus is
within that four year period prior but
it was really interesting to learn about
that and the the adductor and just my
biggest thing that I've learned in the
last four years that I love that I never
hear people talk about is tissue
quality that's been huge for me just
like like fashio like these kids
probably you know they're too athletic
and no deal with that [ __ ] but old folks
like yeah of course
do you watch the film of them lifts yeah
that's that's the game I believe in that
[ __ ] yeah I know dick and I can see
little like even when my like as I've
started getting a little more flexible a
little stronger but my friends come like
that you know even like my buff friends
I'm like how about flexibility so like
you know like we'll play that I'll play
that game before they blow me out and
like lifting all these guys have no [ __ ]
ain't normal folk you know they have no
[ __ ] flexibility like well that's
what I think it that's right in my world
all these people think they're [ __ ]
superstars when they run departments for
my company until you're the [ __ ] CEO
the best part of [ __ ] being somebody
plays 25% of your snaps or kills on
special team is you get to blame the
person ahead of you but when you're on
the [ __ ] lights that's what I love
about sports that I hate about business
you can't count as easily like you miss
a tackle that you're watching on [ __ ]
Sunday Monday whenever [ __ ] you guys do
film that's like you missed that tackle
it's just so much accountability I hate
our [ __ ] company there just could
make it hot they can [ __ ] hide
everywhere they're in a meeting why are
they in that meeting can't can't see
that nobody's I need to start filming
meetings that would be [ __ ] amazing
if we started filming every meeting in
the building and I could watch them and
be like yo what the [ __ ] were you doing
in that meeting
about to give a talk to the band a
football team national champs I'm a
national champ feels natural and even
though I'm rich and I made it and I did
a good thing I like the process I like
the game I like being an entrepreneur
like some of you guys in here love love
playing others are just cool with it
it's your way out there's a million
different variables just some people
can't breathe without it I can't breathe
without the game I can't breathe without
being busy I can't breathe without
working 15 hours a day I can't breathe
without every minute being scheduled you
know I woke up at 4:30 this morning with
the Chicago met with Kraft got on a
plane here now with you guys gonna drive
to Atlanta tonight because I got a
meeting like just in it just and I'm
gonna be in studio with Sonny digital to
3 a.m. tonight and then 7 a.m. be in a
meeting so just in it because I love my
process I love my game and and that is
what I've been spending more time on in
the last three four or five years that's
the thing I think I can bring value here
because you're all gonna have different
paths
the thing that I've become fascinated
with is where's your mind at write to me
for example I'm gonna throw you
something I've been thinking about on
the flight down here to me the craziest
thing is that for most of you your
talent is your vulnerability and that
that like plays with my head the fact
that your talent is actually your
vulnerability because it's been so given
to you you don't even know any different
I know you're talented because I can
context how fast you can run what you
can do what you can live how you can
play but your talent is the
vulnerability and to me how you get over
there and understand that for me what's
super interesting is on some straight
facts for 80% of you this is the apex of
your life you're a bama ball player like
most of you are not gonna be in the
league yet most of you are definitely
not going to be in the league for more
than three years just math and so what
do you do with all the leverage you have
right now you know to me I think a lot
about when I talk to some of the kids on
VM and [ __ ] like that I don't think
about are they really leveraging their
moment do they understand while they're
the big dog on campus right now that the
kids sitting next to them in chemistry
class in six years is gonna have all the
leverage and they're not and they're too
cool to say hello to somebody and that
leverage can change the course of their
life
and so for me you know when I walk here
I've got a few minutes with coach he's
like what are gonna talk about the only
thing that kept running through my mouth
is like who in here which fringe special
teams player which third-string line bag
like who's gonna hear what I have to say
which is this is the greatest era to
ever be a lot alive coach I others we
didn't grow up with this internet thing
the access and ability you have to do
whatever you want is extraordinary
it's almost uncomfortable but and it was
amazing my team couple guys on my team
are here we walked by and big sign the
hall said no excuses I just got so happy
like to me it's just a hundred percent
accountability like like to me this is
all about happiness like life happiness
to me this is just the easiest way I
know how to be happy is to blame myself
for everything all of it
and there's tactics you know I was
talking to coach about et he's my guy
coming through here like he's like été
challenged them to be off social media
for 30 days I was like why the [ __ ]
would he do that cuz that's a tactic
like that's short-term right like that's
cool you check that box but the reality
is it's more about controlling what's
happening to me
technology is the great ammo for you I
hate when people talk about Millennials
and this and that like for me this is it
like this you guys are the best at this
you understand it the best you are the
best version it's always the evolution
but do you know how to make it work for
you that's a mindset game
thank you so much for having me I
appreciate thank you anytime thank you
my god
thank you so much thing my pleasure my
god good luck to see them take care
yourself oh my god take care yourself
thank you thank you so much coming
through
yeah thank you for your question thing
you got it understands leverage it I see
you seeing it leverage it I appreciate
them I thank you for listening
take care yourself thank you so much
thank you thank you so much man good
luck - thank you my god good luck to you
okay yeah thank you thank you my dude
take care thank you appreciate it thank
you thank you thank you thank you love -
thank you take care of something
I thank all y'all not social me on the
table
Thank You Man I I did a kiss Wistia this
and I miss it I have a bigger I got more
money on a shoe deal from k-swiss the
99% of the players in the NFL like you
understand I know she's doing that's why
I did it
Thank You Man thank you for coming
through hope you enjoyed it
of course my god makes every type of
Hemi
thank you ma'am hope you enjoy thank you
that's a question about the social
appreciate it
thank you thank you very time you listen
yes
those [ __ ] guys are amazing you
enjoyed it yeah that's what's up man
Thank You ppreciate slam thanks oh he's
[ __ ] hair thank you yeah man hit me
up let me know how you know I appreciate
a man thanks for listening I appreciate
it big boy I don't think it's done with
but Kryptos [ __ ] gangster right now
like there's so many Joker's in it you
know like it's just it's unstable like
back to the question like Amazon didn't
go to sleep but everybody wants to go
after Bitcoin because they think there's
gonna be a billionaire in a week it's
the same [ __ ] always you know I'll see
to see Thank You Man okay I get your
contact 100 sure thank you man thanks
for listening to me up thank you so much
we're looking at you yeah Gary Vee yeah
hit me up please insures you very much
yeah man I'd enjoyed it
stay well man yeah but you know what
right now everyone's on a high I want to
know about next Thursday all right you
know next Thursday the best flip is
going Craigslist people giving stuff
away for free just go pick it up and you
throw in your truck put on Facebook sell
for 40 bucks of it and like you know
like it needs something like I've all my
fancy friends being like I'm like your
[ __ ] dick you make 400 thousand years
of course eight hundred bucks a month
doesn't mean anything to you I'm like I
came from nothing I know what eight
hundred bucks
you know what 800 bucks a month extra
for you guys are right now I'm gonna do
something with it and the fact they're
like that's like you guys are tough I
don't know I'm not even worried about
you your business your student athletes
you're not even on my radar I'm talking
about people that literally come home at
five o'clock sit on their couch play
three hours of [ __ ] 2k watch eight
hours of Netflix and then tweet that the
world's [ __ ] and it's on you know and
everything sucks I'm like mother [ __ ]
do something you know so for you like
I'm moment like I don't like to say much
to them exams they're treating how hard
they [ __ ] got you working and then
and you got a new class and looking like
whatever the [ __ ] else is going on your
life length I'm like [ __ ] that you guys
are the last people that's half time you
say and you still have time do you know
what I mean
but your biggest problem is the money
day is Saturday morning thank you my god
you know Saturday morning is like garage
sale flea Marty like you know yeah I
mean this the hole is the big game in
that world it's like you go to garage
sales somebody gets no the [ __ ] going
on you buy something for 20 bucks that's
a bunch of video games and you make
eight hundred in one shot
fellas take care thanks for having me
thank you so much for the invite I will
you know thank you guys
take care thank you so much tell coach
tell coach thanks for the hospitality
love you marinate y'all to well touch
hello very good yes
how are you donkey I'm Kim thank you so
much
in this video yeah what up what up nice
to meet you my guy how are you all you
see sorry thank you so much
it's good stuff man that [ __ ] gets me
through my day bro how are you good man
I appreciate that
what's going on inside how are you
what's up fellas
how you been good to see someone no he
has been like two years to make it real
pleasure they killing the gear try man
try man is great miss nice little studio
haven't been through Atlanta in a minute
I was here for like one talk but like
we've been trying to [ __ ] get here
for like a year I didn't even make that
uni me I didn't make that project drop
and was happy seven eight years the loud
noises get you cozy my guy what's up
baby
congratulations man hey good man
Congrats man
you know can we listen to middle fingers
again let's put it on let's play middle
finger on the big speaker goddamnit
what's your take
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh Mike the number one thing that has to
happen with this project it's why I was
just making content for him like
tomorrow morning like you starting right
now you got to go hard like people have
to [ __ ] post that post of the album
cover that's all like you know how it is
right when like a new project drops now
you just need to give everybody needs to
give you cosine with the [ __ ] photo
on it simple as that
it's not complicated you know what I
mean like every producer everybody you
[ __ ] with everybody who [ __ ] with you
just hit like this is not the time to be
bashful or proud it's like yo put this
up do you know what I mean because when
people wake up tomorrow or this weekend
and go through the timeline and they
just see like 15 people they [ __ ] with
with that cover like if you look at like
if like I watch this [ __ ] like if you
look at little baby's project like
that's how [ __ ] happens I like culture
lives on Instagram you went on Instagram
you in real life you lose on Instagram
you lose in real life so to me that's
you know like that's why I just like
putting the story and tagged everything
and pushing it just just that's where
the attention is you know and like and
like you got a win like on Madison
Avenue you got a win in Silicon Valley
you got a win in Hollywood you got a win
in the streets you got it like just win
in every direction but the number one
thing like I think is as many people as
possible next seven to nine days just
throwing up the photo of the project
it's as simple as that
you know what's crazy it's just super
simple to write it's so basic it's like
it's like when we grew up like flyers
it's literally that basic it's just that
basic but it's got it's about like just
not giving a [ __ ] and be like you know
this matters to us is an important
project like to me this is how I think
about [ __ ] this how I think about you
guys just give value give value give
value give value like you give value to
everybody and then once a year when you
need something you just ask and if
people don't come through you don't get
upset you're like yo that's
the way it is who the [ __ ] knows what's
going on with their life you know but
like you get seven out of ten people
that you asked to post it [ __ ]
matters just wait is like think about it
what like outside a [ __ ] rap caviar
outside of a plate like big playlists
like what what else like like what what
are we talking about now music right you
need like either get cosign on some
playlists right which gets you a bunch
of [ __ ] exposure that nobody knew or
you went on [ __ ] Instagram late it's
like literally I think of Instagram
explore and just Instagram feed and rap
caviar the way I thought about music
coming out with MTV and B et and it's it
thank you for watching my stuff what up
vlog it's a you know just a normal 234
in the morning here in Atlanta outside
the studio you know just a normal day
what am i guy it's a real pleasure
real pleasure man I've been looking
forward to it the sunny sunny delay
what's up my guy real good you chuckles
good to see you man good to see you huh
crazy you know we still talking about
Joe oh I I tweeted about it you saw it
I was the one that turns you back I was
like there's Gary B said it we won't
have to do it yeah I love it I like the
wine yeah man I still think about that
all the time literally just as you saw
[Music]
so much so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know what it was like I just feel
like the like the same thing with
anything like people just know people
know when you're slapping your name on
something just trying to make money or
if you're like into it like for me
k-swiss was perfect cuz up I'm 42 so
when I was a kid
k-swiss was real like if you if you
googled k-swiss 1998 es right now the
first three Google Images or dr. Dre
wearing them
ice-t wearing them and Mike Tyson learn
him yeah because some people like corny
corny corny you know like when I first
announced it and I saved all the photos
and I went right into Twitter I was like
reply reply reply and I was like oh [ __ ]
you know cuz there's it out uh-huh
they're like wait a minute I'm like I
said to one cam like yo I remember
sneakers before Jordan had one he was
like what you know that's exactly like I
thought people just were barefoot back
then
[Laughter]
converse has been coming out with some
cool [ __ ] that's some of the new stuff
they've been doing the off-white stuff
is incredible those collabs
they all look cool oh yeah I'm so happy
for him
he broke new ground he did real work
like do you know how many little kids
sitting looking at him now are dreaming
and think they can that [ __ ] matters
that [ __ ] [ __ ] matters people don't
get it how much that people don't do not
understand every subculture like when I
was growing up I was I was born in
Russia when we came to America and being
Jewish and Russia after war was real not
good so for my grandma like you know she
lived in the woods for two years I was I
don't remember I was three when I came
but my grandma she she left when she was
40-something and she grew up she was
born she grew up during the war as a kid
and like after the war World War two
Everybody blamed Jews for everything and
like you know millions of people died
you know millions you know like when six
people died here like millions so it was
[ __ ] up anyway as a kid growing up if
anybody that was Jewish had a Jewish
name showed up on TV my grandma would go
quickly me just eating dinner and like
somebody like Howard Greenberg would be
like talk about some [ __ ] and she would
say in Russian Jew Julie and I and I and
I used to listen no me I thought it was
whatever as I got older older older I'm
like man she came from such a place
where like nobody nobody broke out
everybody was suppressed with the jail
so like you know and so like literally
it was crazy when the Vergil news was
announced it was crazy first thing I
thought about was my grandma I'm like
how many of my grandma little kids who
want to be fashion designer
that are in the hood can't even begin to
think about I'm gonna be the lead
designer for Gucci right now
now just sit there like oh maybe I can
[ __ ] [ __ ] powerful my god yeah man I
wanted to show you real love it stick
this photo I got this boy
I don't think I've posted a 4 a.m.
Instagram post ever
right now
I mean this is absurdity I'm gonna pull
up my Instagram story cuz I'm gonna give
it to you do you want to start this day
with save save with 23 hours in and this
was already in the car it's a 24 hour
[ __ ] there's a banger of a day hey
your play open D Rock
Blagh I love you we did it today we
really did it today the Train knows give
thanks to the Moshe go I'm afraid to be
must give thanks to the Mossad [ __ ]
going platinum I pray to be matzah
[Music]